rupaul what's the uh the game you play
is it dirty sherrod dirty charades baby
okay that's right
every moment i can play it i play i love
to play games dirty charades is my game
you take a title of something and you
just change one word do not change the
syllables you know like um you know like
the movie shampoo i'm that's an old film
you kids don't know what that is yeah
yeah uh shampoo you know uh you could
make it you could it wouldn't be
shampooper you could not make it
shampooper but you could make a shampoop
right yes exactly because you haven't
changed the syllable so that's that's
how you um power the dog power of the
dog power of the power of the snog
pelvis snug yeah that's good snog is an
english thing right that's when you've
done it yeah there you go yeah
can you do one for you can you do an
actual straw before okay all right all
right i have to stand up for this all
right here we go
and you guys can play along you can play
along i can do this okay um
it's a film
four words
second word time
first word
no time no time
no time to die no time no time to time
to die
don't come on your way no no time to
come in your car
what no come on no time to no time to no
time to
wait
away yeah but in
yes yes
[Applause]
oh no kind of jizz no time to jizz of
course
when we play dirty straights this is the
um the universal word for j but you go
uh uh and you go
very different from the charades we
played at christmas yes
i don't know if my mother would have got
that
[Music]